peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si elle n'est pas véritablement
romantique la boîte de nuit est au moins
efficace on y vient avec son plus beau
t-shirt avec sa jupe fendue et son
sourire le plus tendre peu importe la
manière dont on danse et l'heure à
laquelle on ira se coucher
une seule chose compte ici trouver la
femme de ses vacances
à ce jeu les adolescents sont il faut le
dire de loin les plus experts franck et
valérie vous êtes connu en vacances et
on sait qu'on est en vacances
y'a combien de temps et peu près un mois
alors il ya un mois que vous connaissez
on parle toujours des amours de vacances
qui dure jusqu'à la fin de l'été est ce
que vous espérez qu'à l'automne ça va
durer moi j'espère je sais rien j'espère
oui mais il faut aussi penser aux études
si on a l'occasion de se revoir oui mais
sinon pourquoi vous habitez dans la même
région
oui moi j'habite dans le val d'oise fin
lui habite dans l'oise croyait toujours
une possibilité de se voir autant le
romantisme pour vous c'est quelque chose
j'évoque moi vous dire
à 4
[Musique]
à
tu as
[Musique]
à
ma
pas changé
mieux c'est
dans ces grandes manoeuvres de séduction
à chacun sa méthode
après tout seul le résultat compte
[Musique]
en tout cas il est toujours nécessaire
de savoir se servir de ses mains
[Musique]
les fissures là sur la plage ou alors
sur la sur la vie on va leur causer et
puis on comprend leur demande aussi la
rai on verrait en demandent s'ils vont à
ces seules le soir pierre bibeau en vain
pendant les selon les avis peu près
c'est bon on aime bien être dragués mais
on devra quand même dans sa vie à
tendance dont ça se passe bas
généralement c'est sur la plage bon
ouais on essaie de montrer qu'on est là
enfin on attend surtout qu'ils fassent
le premier pas parce que c'est vrai
c'est pas tellement nous qu'ils ont
premier pas
fascinant l'appli de ce fait à la
discothèque on
on regarde bien on fixe et puis pourquoi
si celui qui est en face fixe aussi bon
bah on attend qu'ils invitent pour les
selon jean-charles ça fait longtemps que
j'avais collé bois depuis hier soir
c'est déjà long c'est ça va durer
jusqu'à demain soir
bah ouais j'espérais mais visiblement
pas très sûr baisse plutôt que s'ils
essayent de battre son record alors en
tout cas combien tonnes soit pas à tuer
la combientième quand même type à la 19e
et je crois le 19e il va falloir que tu
te débarrasser rapidement
corinne visiblement tu n'est absolument
pas triste de sattel nous attendent
sinon mes enfants bon ben je passe d'une
main à l'autre c'est pas très marrant
c'est aussi peut-être parce que tu
acceptes bon maintenant on va se faire
accepter en fait ici les filles doivent
accepter de passer de norma ou bien il
se retrouve peut être assez vite tout
seul catalogué oui c'est sur l'axé
passant la maladie
ce parce que
sans peu près tous comme sa mentalité
bah oui alors généralement c'est ici
pendant les vacances la plupart font des
concours ans et les amants de vacances
[Musique]